george what do you make of the fact that
the two first-round picks are matched up
against each other bancaro drifting to
get open and it's buck
sankero trying to post up here against
the shorter knicks
got a little one on him
baseline jumper with a fortuitous role
not just because of where he was picked
because that's just his dna yeah and i
asked jabari pregame how motivated he
was heading into his summer league debut
as ben carroll knocks it
how about the footwork separation
against a very engaging
young man and a guy that like a lot of
young players they have some missteps
earlier in their career but it's all
about learning he talked to us about
improving his diet
it's a discount type inside
and a nice look and fine
[Music]
thank you inside look at his frame
i mean my goodness
big time 6 10 250 pounds use the frame
the ability to get downhill and the
footwork stop apollo
what you got in your game i got plenty
folks
i love the fact doris that vanquiero and
murray are guarding each other in this
game you'd love to see that level of
competition and precision right there by
kennedy
boy look at that frame mark six six two
ten great size so he's gonna be able to
guard he's gotta check
uh pompeiro here that's a problem
with another
little bit of room service at the other
end okay
we're in vegas so we'll take some show
time
he'll be here all week
showing exactly why
competing on the defensive end
a little flair why not it's vegas
[Music]
and let's pray that they continue to
play about four or five games
vancaro trying to turn the corner picked
up by ellis boy
man
spinning like a dj
what a move by banker reacts so quickly
my goodness she ellis that's no wall
[Music]
good double team good dig by ellis
they got the turnover but it goes to
banquero
kicks it out to a wide open terry
butter
surround him and he feels those white
jerseys he's no i've got three somewhere
somebody's open
houston vancouver gets it back shot
clock at three got to get busy with it
tough turnaround cash
the number one pick in the draft against
the number four pick
that carroll
inside terry
got it game over
time to go home
the magic winning